we've all seen those youtube channels
that seem to blow up out of nowhere
they're getting views and subscribers
and it can be
so frustrating when you might feel stuck
you're creating content regularly
but you're just not growing and you've
probably gotten advice like have better
thumbnails or make a better title which
is great advice but if you don't have
that foundation
in place first that advice isn't gonna
help
so in this series this two-part series
we're gonna be breaking down what i call
the clarity equation now this series is
brought to you by the think
master class and i'll tell you more
about that later but if you're new here
welcome my name is heather torres and i
am your host
of the think marketing podcast and if
you're new we release a brand new
episode every single tuesday so i want
to encourage you to subscribe
wherever you're listening to this
content on now we are heading into a
two-part series that's all about the
clarity equation this is going to help
you learn how do you actually get clear
on the type of content you're creating
on youtube
but even more than that how do you get
clear
on where you want to go on youtube now i
gave this keynote that we're going to be
breaking down into two parts
at an event where i was speaking to a
room full of creative entrepreneurs
just like you and in this session i
really dive into the clarity pieces
of youtube in part one here you're gonna
be learning the three main
objections that rise up when you're
getting started
how to go deeper into finding your
reasons for doing what you're doing
and figuring out who you want to help
and how you want to help them
and then we're going to dive deeper into
part two on next week's episode
so let's dive into that talk right now
anyone remember
algebra you know back in school you
remember algebra not my favorite subject
but we're gonna go with it today
so i call this my clarity equation we're
going to solve this
today together we're going to solve this
together today o plus r
plus w plus g plus c
all multiplied by a equals p
now let's go ahead and get started with
o o o o
we need to overcome our objections to
video
we need to overcome them and there's
three major objections when we have
clients that come to us
these are our three i don't have enough
time
i definitely don't have enough money to
go on this adventure
and i have no clue how to use a dslr
camera
or have any idea what f-stop and frame
rates
and all these things that these
photographers do around i have no clue
what those things are
i am not skilled at this well here's the
thing
if you don't prioritize your life
someone else will
if you do not mark your time
someone else is going to take it and so
you need to be the one that's
marking out what are you doing
so raise your hand if you have kids
raise your hand if you have kids nice
and high
okay leave them up raise your hands if
you
also have a job are you sure if you have
a job you don't have kids and a job you
can have one or the other
raise your hand if you have a hobby
raise your hand if you have ministry
um things that you do okay look everyone
look around
everyone every single person in here
has the same amount of time we all have
24 hours
and i like to look at chip and joanna
games i mean anyone love chip and joanna
gaines i'm obsessed
with all their stuff at target right now
it's so cute right
chip and joanna gaines have the same 24
hours they also have
four kids they run multiple businesses
they have
tv shows they help out charitable
organizations they're writing books
you know how they do it all because they
prioritize
their time you need to stop
managing your time and actually
manage your focus because we all have
the same 24 hours
so it's about managing your focus
now here are three ways that i learned
as a young entrepreneur
as i started having kids and we started
moving around the country and really
just
trying to figure out like how do i grow
this business how do i do all the things
because
i want to be a great mom and i want to
be a great wife and i
i want to be able to grow a business i
know it's possible
the first thing i had to learn how to do
was block my calendar
i had to own my calendar this is so
shocking to me
when we have clients come to us and and
i start going through a clarity
um workshop with them i am shocked
how many people do not plan their
calendar now yes you probably plan like
your work day right you're like i got a
meeting at nine and i'm gonna go to
lunch with joe at 12 and you know you
have those things but like
what are you doing with the rest of your
time
how many shows are we binge watching how
many times are we scrolling through on
the internet
that is the time that you need to be
blocking so you need to actually have
real solid blocks of time from when you
wake up in the morning
until you lay your head down on that
pillow every minute
should be blocked because we're only
here for a short amount of time and i
know that you
have something that you need to give to
people and you can't do that
if you're on instagram you cannot do
that
if you're scrolling facebook or you're
binge watching that next show
it is important that you use the minutes
that you have right now
to help the people that you want to
serve the second thing you need to do
and this
ladies tell me if this is hard it seems
so hard for ladies right you have to say
no this is a hard one right because your
girlfriend's like hey you want to go for
drinks and you're like
i really do kind of want to but i gotta
make that next blog post or
hey uh you know my my son's gonna have
another birthday party
but again yeah it was last year and it's
coming around again you know like
that happens all the time this is the
thing ladies and gentlemen
everything that you say yes to
you are saying no to your dream
every time that you say yes to someone
else's agenda
you are saying no to what you know is
right here
you know it it's right there and you're
saying no to your dream
so i challenge you this week before you
say yes to something pause
say what am i saying no to and the last
thing is
you need to really prioritize what
matters so when i take just a second
right now
and i want you to think what matters i
have
four main buckets that i operate off of
one my family if it does not fit into
the bucket of my
family i say no the second
my business if it is not going to move
my business
forward yes it might be nice but is it
going to move my business
forward i say no
the third bucket i have is my community
i love to serve in my community
so if it doesn't fit into that bucket i
say no
and lastly is our customers if it is not
helping me with my customers like if
it's not
helping in some way if i'm not able to
give an hour of time here
or help someone uh put a conference
together or something like that
i say no all right so we've tackled time
now we're going to tackle money tackling
money
when you think about getting into video
usually what pops in your head is
what camera do i buy well you can go to
youtube right now and google that sean's
video will come up and we'd love to
explain that to you but
here's the thing this is what we
normally think about
when we think about getting into video
right you need the camera
you need the lights you need the
backdrop you need all the things right
you need all the things
but you know i want to do something real
quick uh do you have a smartphone
if you have a smartphone can you pull
out your smartphone real quick if you
have a smartphone with you just grab it
just just grab it hold it up really high
i want to see
this is not an android versus uh iphone
okay it's okay
a smartphone of some kind awesome
all of you right there that just held
that up you hold the powered video
in the palm of your hand congratulations
give yourself a round of applause
really that's only that's all you need
all you need right there is your
smartphone
we've already established this video is
free
it's free so let's get rid of the excuse
that it's about the money
because it's not it's about our idea of
thinking we need to have the perfect
video
not the video that's just giving content
to the customers that need it
and the last thing is the skill is the
skill raise your hand if this
is your objection to getting into video
the skill
that's it everyone else is doing video
amazing i love that
remember ranger in your hands nice and
high there we go all right so this skill
so i want to tell you a little story uh
four years ago i
i actually never had a video online four
years ago
i was not the person in front of the
camera
i was not the person standing on stage
and speaking that was just not me
but i knew that i needed to get into
video
and so i decided to open up a snapchat
account
you know what snapchat is raise your
hand if you know what the platform
snapchat is
okay snapchat is like um instagram's
little sister
who uh just couldn't figure out how to
like get going so snapchat's
really not where people are but this is
a good thing this is a good thing
what i did is i opened up a snapchat
account and here's the reason why
because no one's on snapchat really
that's why i did it no one's on snapchat
so i opened up this snapchat account and
i decided that i was going to make
a story a story is a series of 15 second
videos
i was going to make a story every day i
was going to do five stories
every day and i was gonna tell a story
through those five videos that i was
posting and so i did this
and i did it for 30 days and i decided
to do it for another 30 days
and another 30 days and here's why
because when you first start out on
video your voice kind of sounds funny
right like when you first start out
you're like that's what i sound like
what i'm not high pitch apparently i am
right the second thing is is like you're
holding you're holding it
and you're like is that what i look like
on film so the point of doing the
snapchat
challenge was that i just needed to get
comfortable
talking to the camera i just needed to
get comfortable telling a story
i needed to get comfortable being on
that side that side of the lens
i was always a person on the other side
and so to put my face out there
my voice out there and you know all of
my flaws out there
that's why i did the snapchat challenge
and you know what i'm so grateful that i
did because
because of that challenge and connecting
with sean and building this business
that we have
i was able to now teach
on film and this is an amazing
opportunity that we had to
live teach to thousands of people and
our internet went down
yeah anyone have that happen yes so we
luckily went over to a friend's house
and
used his internet and i am standing on a
box you'll see this i'm
in my sock standing on the box because
sean is 6'3
and i'm 5'5 so the camera didn't know
who to focus on so
i got to stand on a box that was fun and
you know i'm so grateful that i did that
snapchat
challenge because then i was able to
speak on stages
and i'm so grateful that i did that
snapchat challenge because
now i go live on instagram i'll go live
on youtube
the people on the other side of the lens
they're just my friends now
i'm not scared of them anymore and i'm
so grateful that i did the snapchat
challenge because now we've built
a community of entrepreneurs thousands
of entrepreneurs
and we're able to live teach to them
every single month
inside of our inner circle program and
i'm so grateful for
doing the snapchat challenge because now
i interview entrepreneurs
just like catherine is stone coat and
i'm just so grateful
that i took that step and put myself
out there and started to do video
don't let fear hold you back
don't let fear hold you back
now yes we can say it's time yes we can
say that it's money
or that it's skill but here's what it
really is
like if we get honest with ourselves
what it really
is is we're afraid of failing
and we're afraid of judgment and that
little girl inside
in sixth grade that used to get teased
she's still in there
but you know what if fear is what we're
gonna let
hold us back we won't ever make progress
and i want to speak to real quick all
the women in this room right now
all the women in this room right now
it is a privilege it is a privilege for
us
to be able to speak on camera
and let me tell you why because there
were trailblazers before us
and we need to be the trailblazers for
the generations of girls behind us
that need to see that our voices matter
that the craft that we know that we have
it matters
and that we have something to bring
to the world that's beyond just being
inside the home
that we have something that they can
follow in the footsteps of
if they don't see it they won't know
that they can do it too
so don't let fear hold you back
don't let judgment of what you think
it's gonna be like
hold you back i mean let me just be
honest
for like four days this is crazy i'm
telling you this
for like four days i worried about what
i was gonna wear today
you know like four days four days out of
my life
i was like should i wear heels should i
wear a skirt
should i look fancy should i wear a
blazer you know
i went like ladies come on right yes
come on yeah you know what i could have
done with that time
i could have figured out what read aloud
i wanted to read to my kids
i could have decided what next course i
wanted to create for entrepreneurs just
like you
i could have been sleeping
but instead for four days i worried
about being judged
i worried about what were you going to
think that i was thinking that you were
thinking about what i was looking like
here on stage
it doesn't matter that doesn't matter
what matters is the message and so i
just challenge you to just get rid of
those insecurities
can we just let those go can we just
decide right now
in this room that we're going to step
out that we're not going to let fear
hold us back
any longer that we are here to make a
difference
that we have something inside of us that
is for people
are we going to make that commitment yes
[Applause]
all right so we've solved o in our
equation we're going to get right to
the r the r of the equation kaylee are
you taking notes because this is school
okay good just want to make sure okay so
r is your reasons and i
love that mike started with this today
too because really at the core of any
business
it's the reasons why we're doing it the
core of every business
is actually us knowing that we were
struggling with something
and that now we know that other people
struggle with it and that we need to
help them
that's really what it boils down to so
what's your why
what is your why for being in business
what is your why for creating what you
create
what's the why here's my why
these four humans are the reason
that i get up every morning and run a
business
these four humans right here are my
thing that gets me through the hard days
these four humans are the reason
that i want to help entrepreneurs i want
my boys and i want my daughter
to know that their mama knew
in her heart that she was supposed to
help people and that she did it
that's what i do that's my reason why
thank you i'm not going to cry so
reasons come before results have you
realized that
the reason that you're staying up late
the reason you're getting up early
the reasons that you're not going on
that summer vacation this year the
reason that you've decided to
step out and start a business the
reasons have got to come before results
because there will be days that will be
hard
there will be challenges in your life
that are going to come up against you
and if you don't have those reasons
drilled
in if they're not like deep in there
like
deep in there you're going to quit
that's what's going to happen you're
gonna quit and so the reasons have to
come before results
so i'm gonna take just a minute and i
want you to label your
four reasons you are in business what
are your four
reasons that you are in business so
w we need to define our who
who's this for who are we creating for
now in any business it's really
important to define like kind of who
you're
doing business for but in online
business
to break through the noise with video
you got to be
super specific on who that is and when i
mean super specific
i mean that you can imagine a person
in your mind you know what they look
like
you know where they live you know their
social economic status their family
status their income level
their skill level you know
the person it's got to be a who in order
to break through
with video so who
is your person now here's the thing if
you try and reach
everyone you'll end up reaching no one
if you go out there and start making
video
and you try and reach everyone on the
internet we hear this all the time when
we get clients
i want to reach everyone okay if you try
and reach everyone
you're not going to reach anyone so i
want you to define
your avatar avatar is just another great
way of saying
your person rachel hollis calls it her
her
you want to define your person
so here's our people this is our person
this is
a group of people at our uh business and
marketing mastermind
that we host every year in las vegas and
this is our her
this is our hymn um i say her and him
because well there's sean and heather
and we both kind of
you know uh go to different types of
people people attracted to us for
different reasons
but these are our people this is our
tribe
these are our people and here here's who
they are here's my her
she's a smart entrepreneur she's smart
she's not dabbling she's ready to
dominate
she just needs a guide she needs a
friend who's a little bit further ahead
of her than
than she is in business and she wants to
know all the mistakes
not to make and she's a hustler
meaning she's a person who's a go-getter
and she's not really after the money of
it you know it's not about really the
the lights and the fame and that kind of
thing it's about
impact it's about impacting the world
you know she is that she understands
that investing in her future
is smart and she's purpose driven
her business has a purpose behind it
it's not just a business out there to
make money
it is there to serve people
so can you picture that person in your
mind right now
do you know who you're making the craft
for
do you know who your best customer is
that you're like if i
only had that customer every time
that'd be amazing that person
that's your her so on social media you
need to define this
this is really important this goes on
your instagram profile
this goes on your facebook profile this
goes on your linkedin profile
this declares who you help
and how you help them so here's a very
simple
sentence this is what we call our
elevator pitch
i help blank do blank
i help fill in the person you serve
entrepreneurs
do what grow their business with video
very simple sentence now i don't mean to
offend any business owners
in here but people actually don't care
about your business
i know that's really hard to sometimes
take because it's our baby right
it's this is i've had it for this long
and it's super important to me
but they actually don't care about their
your business
they care about how can you help me
that's what they care about so here's
some examples for you
this is um alexis she's one of our
members of our inner circle
program our program that we have at
think media
and she is a tiny home builder and so
she
helps tiny home enthusiasts achieve
their goals of creating a more
fulfilling lifestyle and home
that's her profile so if you go to
alexis's instagram page
you click on it and you'll be like oh
wow alexis helps
tiny home enthusiasts and this can go
across
any niche this will be any business this
is diego he's a music teacher
in miami and he helps kids specifically
see that kids that's different than
helping an adult
and he helps him learn how to play
current songs
not old-fashioned songs current songs
with piano and guitar and then there's
my friend nicole she's a pediatric
occupational therapist and she helps
moms very specific
moms enhance their child's development
through
education and fun learning activities
so here's your sentence i help blank
do blank i help fill in the blank
do you can change that around do grow
build you can move that word around but
that's the gist of your sentence
so you take just a second and fill it in
i help
blank do blank well that was part one
of this series where we dove into
overcoming objections
figuring out your reasons and knowing
who your who is
and i have a couple questions for you
what objections are getting you
stuck is it time is it money is it skill
have you identified that objection
because i want to help you identify it
so we can grow past it
i know that for me it was definitely the
skill
i sometimes feel paralyzed with cameras
and microphones and lighting and i mess
it up
all the time and so for me my biggest
hurdle
in waiting three years longer than i
should have was actually understanding
that this skill can be taught that i can
learn about cameras and microphones and
lighting
and how to sound good on camera or look
decent on camera
this is a skill that i needed to
overcome so i want to ask you
what was your main objection was it time
was it money
or was it skill then we learned about
your reasons and after the year we've
had of 2020
knowing your reasons why you're doing
this i think is even more
important you know for me it is the
three kiddos that i have and my husband
my reason is because i want to create a
family environment that fosters learning
i want to
get up every day and feel passionate
about the work that i'm doing
i want to make an impact in the world
beyond just pushing papers or
scheduling social or doing something
that doesn't seem to have meaning
i want to do something that's going to
make an impact in your life
i want to take the mistakes that i've
had and i want to help you go
faster without making those same
mistakes i want to take the mess of
who i am and the flaws that i have and i
want to help you gain
confidence in knowing that you can do
this too if a mom of three who
homeschools who doesn't know how to turn
on the camera can figure this out
you can too and so i just want to be
here as an encourager
as a friend as a guide as a leader as a
mentor
to help you do the same thing and so
your reasons for doing this
are critical it's so important to know
that if you don't have your reasons
mapped out that when you get to hard
days
and you're going to have them it's going
to be so much harder to get through them
but when you know your reasons when
you're writing them out when you have
that in the forefront of your mind it
makes it so much easier to push through
on hard days
and to enjoy the good days and then
lastly we defined
your who who is he who is she have you
defined that person yet
you know for me specifically this took
so much time to get to
because i wanted to help everyone i have
a heart to serve
and i really wanted to help all types of
people
but over time i've realized that if i
want to break through
i need to be known for one thing which
means
i need to figure out who my target
audience is i need to figure out how i
can
uniquely help them and then i need to
give it my all
in that space so i want to encourage you
have you figured out who you're who
is you know even here at think media
over and over
we are clearly defining this as a team
when we started this podcast the think
marketing podcast we had to
go back to the drawing board and say are
we reaching the right person
are we helping them in the right way are
we delivering the right
value to them what makes us different in
the market when we wanted to create this
podcast
and i honestly think we're still
developing that we have an idea
of who we want to help and with your
feedback it's helped us more and more
realize who you are and how we can help
you the value we can bring
to your life so have you written this
out
do you know your who have you decided
what market you want to attack and have
you decided
that it's time to stop dabbling and it's
time to
dominate because there is so much
potential right now on youtube but if
you're not
clear about how you're going to break
through the market
it's going to be so hard to actually get
discovered
now this episode and next week's episode
are brought to you
by the think master class this is our
one hour
free youtube class that you can take
right now when you're done listening to
this podcast
i recommend that you block time on your
calendar that you
set aside one hour to go deeper on how
to do
youtube right this is a class that gives
you the three secrets for success on
youtube and
we share case studies of people just
like you who are using
the actual strategies that we teach
inside of our academy
we're teaching them to you for free and
we're sharing with you some case studies
of people
who have not only gone full time who
have made six-figure brand deals and
who now are over 100 000 subscribers
on youtube if that's one of your goals
if you want to get brand deals if you
want to grow your channel to over 100
000 if you want to go full time on
youtube
then this is the class that you need to
take and i'm excited because
we have a brand new update coming of
this class so make sure you watch the
current one right now
and make sure you're ready for the
upcoming class that's coming soon
you'll also want to make sure that you
are subscribed so that when we get to
next
week's episode you are ready i'm
bringing the fire next week on the
episode that's part two of this clarity
equation
we're gonna be defining your goals this
is
critical as an entrepreneur which is who
you are and knowing the goal
knowing the target is so important so
we're going to dive into
knowing the goals how to create what we
call
the napkin strategy so many people over
complicate
what it means to create content and i'm
gonna simplify that
down to a napkin and then we're gonna
close
by learning the best ways to multiply
your success
all that's happening on next week's
episode of the think marketing podcast
so you're going to want to make sure
that you are subscribed and ready for
when it's released
and when you are done listening to this
episode head over to itunes and rate and
review
i'd love to read what keith strong said
he said phenomenal podcasts super dope
content
and can listen while i work you guys are
online
world changers keep up the good work
thank you so much keith for writing that
review
over on itunes and if you've not written
your review yet we would love
to read it please head over to itunes
you can rate it by letting us know what
you think about the podcast
writing a review and maybe you'll be
featured on a future episode
i want to thank you for your time i know
that your time is super valuable so
thank you so much for
spending this time with me and we will
see you
in the next episode